I'm very happy in all areas of my life
and I feel really blessed and really
lucky and now Katherine Schwarzenegger
Pratt can add a baby to her list of
blessings the 30 year old is expecting
her first child with hubby Chris Pratt
tell me babies IIIi can't give away
spoilers the eldest child of Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Maria Shriver first
sparked pregnancy rumors during her
March 10th appearance on live with Kelly
and Ryan please welcome Catherine
Schwarzenegger Pratt Catherine's overly
cautious elbow bump amid coronavirus
concerns and her loose-fitting dress are
what gave it away
so you have so much to celebrate lately
right thank you I think you've got
married you turned 30 Catherine and
Chris's relationship has been a
whirlwind from the start they were first
linked in June 2018 after they were
spotted picnicking in Santa Barbara
California pretty magical Chris made
their relationship Instagram official
that December posting a sweet collage in
honor of Catherine's 29th birthday and
by January 2019 they were engaged a
source told et at the time that they got
engaged quick but everyone around them
saw it coming
adding that they're a great couple that
have a solid foundation I'm a man of
faith and I believe that God works in
mysterious ways and gives us signs and
gifts in life and those gifts oftentimes
come in the form of people the famous
duo made their red carpet debut at the
Avengers and game premiere in April
where Chris had this to say about
wedding planning are you deeply involved
am i deeply involved you know I'm up to
about my neck you know that's not that's
pretty deep that's about five foot
something to hear so you're in it I'm in
it baby how minute well it's good it
feels good
Schwarzenegger and Pratt tied the knot
several months later on June 8th the
next day they both shared this photo
from their wedding and
called it the best day of their lives
this is not something I ever imagined
Pratt is already a proud papa to seven
year old son Jack who he shares with
ex-wife on a Ferris
[Music]